[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes le lundi 3
septembre très heureux de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle saison du 7-8 journal
sur tv 78 tout de suite les titres de
cette édition la fin des vacances d'été
ce matin plus de 300 mille jeunes
yvelinois ont repris le chemin de
l'école avec des nouveautés une rentrée
préparé depuis quelques jours par les
enseignants une rentrée vous le verrez
également perturbé en raison de
plusieurs préavis de grève déposé par
les professeurs les 20 ans du medef
l'organisation patronale a fêté cet
anniversaire lors de ses universités
d'été la semaine dernière à jouy en
josas pour en parler didier baichère est
notre invité le député l om et des
yvelines a présenté sur place
le projet de loi pacte aux dirigeants
d'entreprise c'est l'une des priorités
de la rentrée pour le gouvernement
et puis là de la célébration de la
victoire des bleus à la coupe du monde à
l'effroi du double meurtre de trappes
l'actualité n'était a été dense dans les
yvelines
retour sur les principaux événements de
juillet à août à la fin de ce journal
et puis autre invité de ce journal le
conseiller départemental l ère du canton
de trappes nicollin dainville qui nous
rejoindra en deuxième partie de ce
journal ce chiffre pour débuter 304 1500
le nombre de jeunes vivent les noix
écoliers collégiens et lycéens qui
reviennent en classe à partir
d'aujourd'hui certains pourront
bénéficier de nouveautés à retenir le
dédoublement des classes mises en place
pour les cp de trappes notamment l'an
passé qui était étendu à tout le réseau
d'éducation prioritaire ainsi qu'aux
classes de ce1 du réseau d'éducation
prioritaire renforcée est des sections
sport ouverte aussi dans deux collèges à
guyancourt et montigny le bretonneux
enfin une première dans les yvelines
c'est le lancement d'une unité pour
l'autisme dans une maternelle aux
mureaux la rentrée des classes est
forcément un moment important pour les
enfants et parents très excitation
stress inquiétudes parfois comme en
cette première matinée at elle été vécue
à l'école jules-verne de montigny le
bretonneux propos recueillis par patrick
jacques de dixmude à des chiliens fâché
on a fait des petits travail
on a créé les devoirs pour maladie je
retrouve mes amis c'était bien et bas au
début je savais pas trop où est ce
qu'elle était ma classe mais j'ai vu mes
copains il me faisait concours et du
coup gestion ou est ce que c'était y a
pas eu de mal ma maîtresse elle est très
gentille
j'ai bien aimé ma maîtresse on a fait un
peu de conjugaison et du français
on est arrivé on a joué dans la cour et
puis après on est rentré aux classes
d'abord on a fait une petite luna fait à
une chanson on a mis un doigt sur la
mappemonde et où la fée tournis pour
savoir dans quel endroit du monde
on pourrait voyager une rentrée préparez
dès la semaine dernière par les
encadrons ils sont 26 mille tous métiers
confondus dans le département au
programme réunion dans les
établissements et accueille des nouveaux
professeurs de l'académie de versailles
mélanie poker a suivi ces préparatifs
[Musique]
dans la classe de madame barbier la
rentrée se fait en chansons pour ses 21
élèves c'est double niveau cm1 cm2 une
rentrée en douceur mais une rentrée
active
le principe c'est que dès qu'on commence
l'année et faut tout de suite que les
enfants comprennent qu'elles seront les
attentes de l'enseignant qui les prend
en charge
il est important tout de suite de
marquer des limites forte de manière
après nous pouvons assouplir les règles
cet établissement de guyancourt accueil
117 élèves si les écoliers ont retrouvé
leur classe matin les professeurs sont
sur le pont depuis la semaine dernière
on prévoit tout ce qui est organisation
de l'école donc tout ce qui est
récréation
pas une vraie création planning de de
sport est ici d'organiser au mieux les
informations qu'on a des anciennes un
ancien enseignant pour les transmettre
aux nouveaux deux professeurs ont
intégré cette équipe des stagiaires qui
ont réussi le concours 2018
ils sont près de 400 pour le département
des yvelines
c'est plus important que l'année
dernière notre département et évolue
dans sa démographie
alors assez peu pour le premier degré
puisque en fait cette année cette
rentrée présente on attend moins
d'élèves que l'année dernière c'est un
passage un petit peu un passage à vide
mais nous avons besoin de nouveaux
professeurs et nous en accueillons plus
d'une cinquantaine de plus
comparativement à l'année dernière
je m'y attendais pas forcément mais sur
la liste du travail
l'excitation est un petit peu dingue de
stress aussi une bonne balance entre les
deux elle les élèves et professeurs sont
partis pour une nouvelle année scolaire
cette semaine de travail avant la
première pause les vacances de la
toussaint
et en ce jour de rentrée certains
enseignants ont fait part de leur colère
les syndicats dénoncent des postes
vacants dans le secondaire un manque
inquiétant de remplaçants dans le
premier degré en conséquence certains
établissements perturbés ce matin elle
notamment au collège de la couldre à
montigny le bretonneux vous le voyez sur
ces images où les professeurs étaient en
grève est dans le viseur des effectifs
surchargés en 6e l'ouverture d'une
classe supplémentaire est demandée
écoutez ses propos au micro au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude
nous avons des effectifs relativement
élevé au collège cette année notamment
6e où nous sommes à 29 par classe et
nous avons également des difficultés par
rapport à la sécurité donc on attend une
commission qui puisse nous indiquer si
on peut pratiquer dans de telles
conditions dans certaines salles du
collège notamment envoyé un signal même
s'il n'ya pas l'ouverture d'une classe
total au moins soutenir permettent de
dédoubler quelques courses à permettra
peut-être de faire passer la pilule
une commission de sécurité doit se
rendre prochainement dans
l'établissement où la rentrée des 6e et
décalé à mercredi est la rentrée c'est
aussi dans les lycées une compétence de
la région ile de france poursuit son
plan d'urgence votée en mars 2010 7,5
milliards d'euros investis sur dix ans
et des axes précis pour cette nouvelle
année est la lutte contre le décrochage
scolaire ou encore l'intégration de
produits locaux dans les cantines ont
fait le point avec mélanie poké nous
venons de mettre en place la grande
nouveauté l'entrée plate forme
téléphonique pour contacter
individuellement et en lien avec les
rectorats chaque décrocheur une
plateforme lancée en mai dernier son
objectif contacter 100% des décrocheurs
ils sont vingt mille en ile de france
qu'ils soient collégiens et lycéens
il ya beaucoup de travaille déjà pour
appréhender vraiment le nombre et la
situation de ces décrocheurs
et puis lorsque nous aurons vraiment
contacter chacun et fiabiliser ce
fichier et nous mettons tous les moyens
pour le faire rapidement prendre au
moins un décrocheur sur deux en charge
dans des dispositifs qui existent ça
change complètement toute l' approche
décrochage ou jusqu'à présent et bien
aux finances et des écoles de la
deuxième chance des structures de
raccrochage mais sans se soucier si
elles étaient pleines ou si elle était
vide
et si les jeunes y avaient accès ou pas
est donc là on va aller chercher les
jeunes c'est ça pour nous le social
efficace pour cette rentrée la région
ile de france vise aussi la restauration
scolaire d'ici 2024
elle veut atteindre 100% des cantines en
circuit court avec 50 % de produits bio
l'île de france le produit pas tous
qu'on aura les partenariats avec les
autres régions pour notre
approvisionnement mais on veut du
produit local
et puis on veut que dans ce produit
local 50% soit du produit piot nous
voulons cela parce que nous voulons à la
fois bien manger et nous voulons aussi
un bilan carbone positif de ce que nous
mangeons 100 établissements en
bénéficient déjà pour cette rentrée à
saint quentin en yvelines sont concernés
les lycées 17 main à maurepas rené
descartes et emilie de breteuil à
montigny le bretonneux
il ya des nouveautés de la rentrée il y
en a également dans les transports à
partir de ce lundi le réseau de bus de
saint quentin en yvelines et restructuré
une vingtaine de lignes est concerné
2100 courses supplémentaires seront
proposés par an sur le territoire
si on regarde dans le détail la ligne 8
qui relie la gare de plaisir à celle de
villepreux les clubs aura une course
supplémentaire toutes les 15 minutes en
heure de pointe plus plus de bus
également pour relier le nord de
l'agglomération à la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines les lignes 437 et
464 elles fusionnent
cela permet d'augmenter les courses
entre la gare de saint rémy les
chevreuse et celle de saint quentin en
yvelines
on accueille sur ce plateau notre
premier invité didier baichère bonfort
vous êtes député la république en marge
de la première circonscription des
yvelines alors c'est aussi un moment de
rentrée politique avec quelques coup dur
pour le gouvernement les tergiversations
notamment sur le prélèvement à la source
sera t-il ou non appliquée au 1er
janvier
on peut citer également la démission
nicolas hulot la semaine dernière son
successeur au ministère de l'écologie
sera connue demain c'est une rentrée
mouvementée pour le gouvernement c'est
une rentrée
je crois que l'année dernière c'était
mouvementé également
voilà donc c'est la rentrée et on
reprend les dossiers je pense que la
démission de nicolas hulot a été très
commentée c'est une décision qui est
très personnel - pertile personnel je
regrette je regrette son départ parce
que je pense que la transition
écologique c'est un sujet qui est plus
qu'important on sait la situation dans
laquelle on est et je crois que quand on
est un défenseur comme lui peut-être on
se doit de passer au dessus de toutes
les difficultés parce qu'être ministre
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué mais je
crois que voilà j'aurais aimé qu'ils
passent par dessus ses difficultés
qu'ils puissent continuer avec nous
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de choses je
pense au glyphosate et qui ont été
faites il ya bien une chose beaucoup de
choses à faire
alors vous étiez à didier baichère à
l'université d'été du medef qui s'est
déroulée le 28 et 29 août sur le campus
de hec à jouy-en-josas
un rendez-vous qui fête cette année ses
20 ans tout comme l'organisation
patronale présidée par geoffroy roux de
bézieux
à deux jours de rencontres de
conférences débats et de plénière pour
penser l'avenir le monde la france l
entreprise dans 20 ans mélanie poker et
michael et demi d'euros étaient sur
place
pas de nostalgie pour son anniversaire
pour ses 20 ans le medef regarde vers
l'avenir et pense à l'entreprise dans
deux décennies et
bien et des consommateurs l'entreprise
que nous sommes aujourd'hui c'est décidé
il ya 50 ans et on travaille à
stabiliser à pérenniser l'entreprise
pour les 50 prochaines années chez
sodexo pour nous l'entreprise si vous
voulez c'est une communauté c'est une
communauté d intérêts de ses
actionnaires de ses salariés de ses
fournisseurs et de ses clients
allez donc tout est décliné avec en
faisons en réalisant cette synthèse une
réflexion tournée vers le futur choisi
par le nouveau président du mouvement il
eut en juillet dernier les entreprises
tournées vers l'europe les nouvelles
technologies l'intelligence artificielle
c'est un élève de proposition à mme neff
qui va qui va regarder les autres qui va
proposer et qui va être dans la
concertation
on est aujourd'hui dans une économie de
confiance de confiance confiance avec
nos partenaires confiance avec les
politiques confiance avec les salariés
confiance et ça se bâtit on est dans un
monde qui bouge énormément
je pense que le grand groupe en lui même
les grands groupes tels qu'on les a
connus notamment en france vont être
amenés à bouger
ils vont peut-être changer énormément de
l'intérieur les start up sont en train
de grossir aussi donc elles vont aussi
venir sa ligne et plus de 4500
entrepreneurs ont répondu présent cette
année les syndicats en profiter de
l'événement pour se rassembler près de
200 d'entre eux contractés durant la
matinée du vote de foot à l'entrée du
campus
on a des propositions sur le statut de
l'encadrement le droit à la déconnexion
l'équilibré vie privée-vie
professionnelle l'égalité femmes-hommes
aussi qu'être est une revendication très
importante voilà et puis bah montrer une
présence montrer valaques yad'autres
d'autre choix possible que ce que
cherche à imposer le medef pour la
rentrée une intersyndicale appelle déjà
la mobilisation le 9 octobre pour
protester contre la politique sociale du
gouvernement
vingt ans donc eu du mouvement des
entreprises de france qu'est ce que ça
signifie
didier baichère quelle importance
finalement à le medef dans le paysage
français
aujourd'hui il représente les patrons
français dont je pense que c'est un
syndicat qui est important dans au-delà
de ça je pense que la présence à
l'université du medef est extrêmement
importante l'ensemble de la politique on
qu'on mène depuis 2010 16 allait centrer
sur faire réussir le travail gagner la
bataille de l'emploi et qui dit gagner
la bataille de l'emploi 10 des
entreprises ou des artisans des pme des
grands groupes
c'est ça en fait qu'on essaye de
travailler avec eux c'est ça qu'on a
travaillé d'ailleurs a vécu pons et
voilà sur place justement vous allez
vous avez fait un peu de pédagogie
notamment présenté la loi pacte vous
êtes membre de la commission spéciale
pour cette fois pacte alors le plan
d'action pour la croissance et la
transformation des entreprises c'est le
dossier de la rentrée économique faire
une présentation détaillée ici serait
peut-être un petit peu long mais que
faut-il retenir finalement que que
va-t-il changer concrètement ce projet
de réforme
j'essaie de prendre deux exemples un peu
extrême qui concerne directement les
entreprises
aujourd'hui il ya 199 seuils différents
d'effectifs suivant à qui vous parlez si
vous regardez le code du travail
parler la sécurité sociale si vous
parlez aux impôts vous n'avez pas les
mêmes seuils d'effectifs à 199 seuils
différents pour les entreprises c'est
beaucoup trop compliqué dans le texte on
propose de le ramener à 3 3 seuil les
mêmes progressivement on va pas faire ça
du jour au lendemain progressivement
15,5 en vain pendant 20 50 et 250
salariés comme ça on harmonise et les
entrepreneurs arrêteront de se poser des
questions tout le temps pour les
salariés il ya une mesure très
importante dans ce texte qui est la
suppression du forfait social donc c'est
10 % des sommes de l'intéressement qui
sont versées qui étaient prélevées dont
qui n'allait pas dans la poche des
salariés pour les entreprises de plus de
faire moins de 250 salariés
donc ça c'est du pouvoir d'achat
directement pour les entreprises et puis
après le texte c'est aussi une dimension
très social puisqu'il ya toute cette
partie d'inclure dans le code civil
l'objet social des entreprises c'est
dire enfin reconnaître que bien sûr une
entreprise c'est fait pour innover
gagner de l'argent mais c'est également
fait pour développer ses salariés
travailler sur la qualité de vie au
travail et on va pouvoir l'inclure
directement dans l'objet des entreprises
dans leur raison d'être
c'est une réforme jugée urgente par le
gouvernement pourquoi fallait-il voilà
la voter l'étudier à l'assemblée
nationale avant la réforme
constitutionnelle parce que c'est une
réforme c'est un texte qui
opérationnelle qui va produire ses
effets immédiatement il ya une partie
par exemple sur les actifs stratégiques
sais qu'il y beaucoup de débats quand il
eut la vente d'alstom est ce qu'il y
avait des actifs stratégiques de donc
pas donc désormais avec la loi pas quand
elle sera elle sera en place on va
pouvoir directement le gouvernement va
pouvoir intervenir directement
lorsqu'il sera question de vendre des
actifs stratégiques éventuellement
opposer son veto et quel retour vous
avez pu avoir justement sur plâtre à
l'université du medef auprès des
dirigeants d'entreprise
excellent il faut se rappeler en fait
que les dix derniers mois qui viennent
de s'écouler ont permis d'avoir cette
concertation avec les chefs
d'entreprises pour construire le texte
sur sur notre territoire avec ma
collègue marie le bec et jean-noël
barrot nous avons mené plusieurs
réunions avec le medef à la chambre de
commerce des yvelines pour rencontrer
les entrepreneurs les pme et les grands
groupes pour challenge est en fête avec
eux ce que nous allons mettre dans le
texte il ya eu vraiment une
co-construction du texte donc c'était
important qu'on fasse la pédagogie
jusqu'au bout avec eux dernière question
le calendrier pour ce projet de loi quel
est il on démarre le balayage des
amendements dans tous les amendements
qu'on va apporter au texte cette semaine
et donc on va étudier
passer à l'assemblée en de mémoire c'est
le 18 septembre quelque chose comme ça
donc ça va aller très vite
il s'agit alors après il ya le sénat
mondial a su aller retour mais l'idée
c'est que ce soit un texte qui puisse
être opérationnel dès 2019
merci à didier baichère d'avoir été avec
nos six députés est l'héroïne de la
première circonscription des yvelines et
je rappelle que vous êtes également un
membre de la commission spéciale pour la
loi pacte retour en arrière à présent
pour la suite de ce journal l'actualité
de juillet et août a été marquée par
plusieurs événements dans le département
des moments de joie et d'excitation elle
mais aussi de tristesse et l'effroi le
résumé de cet été avec nicolas landry
[Musique]
rien
non
[Musique]
oh
et concernant l' attaque au couteau
survenue à trappes l'amène la
municipalité a bien sûr réagi rapidement
après les faits communicants dans un
communiqué pardon condamnant des actes
odieux elle indique qu'elle ne fera
aucun commentaire on va parler de cette
attaque avec un nouvel invité sur ce
plateau nicolas dainville bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes conseiller
départemental les républicains du canton
de trappes en binôme avec anne capio
alors l'enquète est en cours c'est la
piste pour le monde du différend
familial qui semble être privilégié
plutôt que celle du terrorisme
rappelons que l'auteur des faits était
fiché s.nicolas dainville vous estimez
tout de même que que la radicalisation
cet individu a été minimisée pourquoi
leur écoute et wall e le jour du drame
je suis allé sur le terrain j'ai
interrogé pas mal d'habitants
effectivement tous les habitants que
j'ai pu rencontrer m'ont parlé de sa
psychologie fragile de ses antécédents
psychiatriques je crois qu'il était
interné à l'hôpital de charcot à plaisir
également de ces difficultés dans son
couple dans sa famille le décès de son
père qu'il aurait totalement
déstabilisés mais il ya un certain
nombre d'autres éléments qui sont sur la
table effectivement sa présence dans le
fichier des personnes radicaliser son
licenciement de la ratp pour apologie du
terrorisme
le mode opératoire la revendication qui
ont donc jeté le trouble et qui
permettent de s'interroger jeu l'état
islamique a très vite revendiqué cet
acte alors c'est apprendre bien sûr avec
prudence on sait que l'organisation a pu
faire des revendications opportuniste
par le passé notamment après la tuerie
de las vegas aux états unis cédées des
révélations qu'on cus révélées fausses
après par par la suite pourquoi là il
faut quand même parlé de la
radicalisation de sa vie d'individus
selon vous par par sa présence même dans
le fichier d'aidé radicaliser de source
sûre c'est un individu qui était suivi
suivi par les renseignements
donc je pense qu'il faut pas l'occulter
les deux les deux et les deux éléments
sont à prendre en compte avec un
enseignant l'agité psychologique
et sa radicalisation donc voilà qu'on
soit prudent bien évidemment mais qu on
n'occulte pas qu'on ne néglige pas un
des deux éléments qui me semble
important à prendre en compte je
rappelle qu effectivement trap est une
ville qui est bourré de talent bourré
d'énergie mais qui est malheureusement
tristement connu pour être un foyer de
départ départ pour la zone irako
syrienne
le chiffre qui m'a été confirmé par le
préfet ses 67 des parts ce qui est le
record en europe
donc c'est un fait qui est triste un
record qu'on regrette mais qui fait que
tu rappes n'est pas une ville comme les
autres et est donc bien évidemment que
tout ce contexte doit être prise en
compte pour analyser cette situation
alors par le biais d'un communiqué vous
demander un vrai plan d'action de l'état
à trappes quelles pourraient être les
actions concrètes à mettre en place mais
écoutez on parle de ceux qui sont partis
à maintenant ceux qui reviennent le
chiffre qui m'a été donnée par le préfet
c'est le chiffre de 5 c'est à dire sur
les 67
départ 11 auraient été tués au combat
5 serait revenu donc je pense qu'il faut
vraiment une attention très particulière
sur la sécurité
pour vous donner un exemple et un
certain nombre d'autres villes alentour
à trappes qui prennent la menace très au
sérieux avec une police municipale plus
nombreuses une police municipale et
parfois armé pour faire face à toutes
les menaces les menaces naissante
par exemple la mise en place de la
police de sécurité deux quotidiens qui
va intervenir dans les prochaines
semaines
étant une première réponse c'est une
bonne mesure selon vous quelles qu'elles
soient mises en place
attraper l'une des villes retenues par
ce dispositif alors pour que ce soit une
bonne mesure il faut que la municipalité
soit d'accord je pense que la
municipalité n'étaient pas forcément
demandeuses pour ce type de mesures pour
moi la coordination entre forces de
l'ordre et puis équipe municipale est
fondamental s'il n'y a pas cette bonne
coordination ça serait un échec
je pense qu'en termes de sécurité il ya
des quartiers à reconquérir
on parlait de quartiers perdus de la
république ya maintenant des quartiers
interdit de la république avec des
bandes avec la génération des petits
frères c'est plus les grands frères
c'est les petits frères qui font la loi
en 2015 moi j'ai participé à la marche
pour le petit moussa qui avait été tuée
et savait marquer beaucoup les esprits
donc il ya vraiment une reconquête
sécuritaire qui passe
par une police plus nombreuses par ces
bandes qui doivent cesser de faire la
loi
je pense qu'il a une réponse également
en termes culturels long terme éducative
je cite souvent l'exemple de la
fondation espérance banlieues qui sont
ces écoles dans les zones dites
prioritaires qui ouvre des structures
pour redonner confiance aux jeunes des
structures avec de l'ambition qui leur
font découvrir des métiers qui leur
transmettent l'amour du pays
l'amour de la culture française qui les
font sortir des quartiers pour leur
faire voir aussi les beautés de notre
patrimoine
je pense que c'est un une bonne réponse
aux maux de la jeunesse et je serai
d'ailleurs heureux avec tous ceux qui
souhaitent participer au projet d'ouvrir
ce type de structure sur le canton de
trappes à la verrière à elancourt ou
dans la ville de trappes comme ça s'est
déjà fait à sartrouville comme ça c'est
déjà fait a mantes la jolie
et puis enfin je pense conclure bien sûr
qu'à une réponse économique
attrapant à 20% de chômage s'est ain des
records ces doubles même pour les moins
de 25 ans donc il faut renforcer la zone
franche urbaine il faut renforcer les
incubateurs ces jeunes ils ont pas envie
qu'on leur dise qu'il faut pas devenir
milliardaire ou millionnaires ils ont
envie qu'on leur apprennent comment
devenir millionnaire et moi c'est aussi
tout mon combat que j'ai envie de mener
merci à nicolas d'envié d'avoir été avec
nous je rappelle que vous êtes
conseiller départemental les
républicains du canton de trappes
on va enchaîner
[Musique]
c'est une nouvelle rubrique dans le 7-8
journal chaque lundi nous vous faisons
découvrir le parc naturel régional de la
haute vallée de chevreuse ce territoire
s'étend sur les départements des
yvelines et de l'essonne
focus ce soir sur la commune de janvry
qui a renouvelé cette année son
opération gembrie plage ce corps de
ferme transformée en espace de baignade
et de plage a enregistré à cette année
2008 100 adhérents le reportage sur
place et de jules colis malgré sa petite
taille et ses 630 habitants le village
de janvry est connu pour son charme et
ses nombreux événements comme le bar de
la plage qui
tous les étés depuis 20 ans transforme
la petite ferme de janvry en un bord de
mer au coeur de la vallée de chevreuse
la plus ferme de jean brice est un peu
la ferme au mieux le visage on fait tous
nos événements tout au long de l'année
et pendant tout le temps de l'été c'est
200 tonnes de sable une piscine zodiac
40 tonnes d'eau des paliers des jeunes
hommes et des jeunes filles en maillot
de bain des boissons pas cher tout ça
pour les adhérents de l'association et
l'adhésion 5 euros pour toute l'année et
donc du coup toute la saison plage sans
compter le reste des activités
on a un flux de visiteurs de deux
touristes même un peu jamais vu qui fait
qu' on a battu tous les records de des
meilleures saisons à la mi saison
je dirais qu'il ya pas de profil type
ccd gens qui viennent ici trouver un
petit oasis qui ne peuvent pas partir en
vacances reviennent de vacances n'ont
pas de vacances et sort du travail et
qui viennent ici avoir une petite
bouffée d'air pur c'est donc tous les
jours de 11 heures à 19 heures que les
visiteurs peuvent profiter de ce lieu et
de ses diverses activités proposées via
la piscine la grande évidemment pour les
petits et les grands à la piscine pour
les petits et jouets pour le sable deux
tables de ping pong un baby foot on
prête le matériel nécessaire même si on
se baigne pas déjà aulas le genre il
arrive au début un petit peu étonné et
repartent avec le sourire et y
reviennent le lendemain un événement
très populaire qui permet également aux
jeunes de la région de trouver un
travail d'été très formateur
c'est une vingtaine d'emplois qui sont
créées qui permettent aux jeunes c'est
de janvry et des environs aussi parce
qu'on n'est pas on n'est pas sectaires
de se faire une première un
professionnel il gagne un petit pécule
pour pouvoir partir en vacances
notamment janvry est véritablement
promoteurs de toute idée neuve oublier
parfois avant gardiste pour proposer
justement des solutions aux gens pour
sortir de chez eux se rencontrent et
passer un bon moment
un bon moment que les deux mille trois
cent cinquante adhérents du mois de
juillet ont grandement apprécié un
chiffre record qui illustre bien la
devise du village l'art de mieux vivre
ensemble
c'est la fin de ce journal l'édition est
à retrouver sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile excellente
soirée et très bon début de semaine à
tous sur tv 78
[Musique]